this is
the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
author of the number one best-selling
book debt-free degree how to send your
kiddo to school
debt free or if your kiddo how you go to
school
completely debt-free no reason to
participate in this
student loan nightmare that is in
america right now why would you sign up
for that trip
anthony can help you not do that we're
here to talk to you about your life and
your money the call is free some say
it's worth what you pay for it
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five jonathan's in charleston
south carolina starting off the hour hey
jonathan how are you
good dave how are you and anthony better
than we deserve sir how can we help
long story short military we're about to
relocate
from south carolina to connecticut uh
the housing market is very expensive up
there so we're fortunate enough to where
we're selling here in charleston
and we hopefully should make over a
hundred thousand on our home here
and when we go to connecticut based off
the market up there we thought it'd be a
wise decision just to go to base housing
that way when i retire in three years i
don't have to worry about selling and i
can pocket a lot of cash
amen my question my question is
for the next three years what should i
do with this large amount of money that
i'm about to cash out of my home here
and if we know where we want to end up
at the end of my
military career is it wise to go ahead
and purchase
land if we could pay cash for that and
sit on it until we're ready to build a
home in three years when
i retire well thank you for your service
yeah absolutely uh let me ask you this
question um
do you know for sure for sure where you
want to be settled at
i do we both my life is retired military
already and then like i said after years
left and we want to end up
somewhere around asheville or knoxville
somewhere and
toward the eastern part of tennessee why
i'm originally from memphis
and uh close enough to family but far
enough away
and just we love tennessee we'll be at a
point in both of our careers that
we will have our military pensions so it
will be at the point our lives to where
we get to do what we want so the job
it's a factor but it's not a huge factor
because i believe i can find something
wherever we end up
here and that's three years down the
road right yeah yeah
correct and dave may have something
different on this one but for me
i'm fearful about making a three-year
decision especially when it comes to
dirt
you know i'm just not cause a lot can
change and
a lot can happen within a matter of
three years
i'm not a fan of you uh purchasing that
now i would be
says a guy who's on four different
pieces of real estate in the past two
years
[Laughter]
exactly but see that's why because i got
a chance to live in a tent
is that i might be moving again
yeah probably it's it's like a thing
yeah i think he's right though i i think
what i would do
is i'd want to settle into an area and
make sure i landed my career there
yeah um and you know i i obviously love
the mountains and the appalachian
mountains in east tennessee that's where
i was born is
it's uh what causes my blood to pump so
i love the area
i'm with you on it's beautiful i'm with
your general concept
asheville is a considerably different
city
than knoxville like way different
absolutely yeah one one is a
conservative college town and one is a
hipster craft beer town
yes and so um just way different
politics way different vibe
way different everything the only thing
they have in common is the market and a
state line near both of them absolutely
but uh both wonderful towns it's just a
matter where you want to be so i think
you settle in then
and so where do you park it in the
meantime uh you get you got two choices
you can take zero risk and make almost
no money sticking it in a money market
or you can take a little risk and drop
it into something like a no load
uh uh s p 500 that's where i park money
on the short term but i'm willing to
take the risk that that hundred thousand
might go down to ninety five thousand
if you do that it might go up to 115 000
that's why you take the risk yeah but it
might go down to 95
during that three years it's possible i
mean uh but a three year period
and just no commission on it so you're
not you don't have to make that up
over the long haul i don't mind paying
commission on funds my funds and my 401k
are commissioned funds but the
um but they're in there for the long
haul where you're just sitting on three
years like that just a no-load with
meaning no commission uh and or you
could put
50 000 in that and 50 000 in the bank
and that would limit your risk a little
bit more kind of take a middle ground
yeah that's the goldilocks approach just
right but the uh
one's hot and one's cold and you know so
anywhere in there
but i think anthony's giving you really
good wisdom there and again thank you
for your service but when you come out
of the military you're gonna
have a lot of changes uh i mean you've
had a very structured
uh obviously life for 20 years your wife
has as well
uh up until her retirement and and
you're gonna land and
you don't have to do anything because
you've got two great sets of retirement
but you're likely going to want to do
something that gives your life meaning
in your career
and i'd want to settle all of that yeah
and then buy the land
yeah get to know the area well enough
before you buy the land too it doesn't
hurt to rent an area for that you don't
know anything
about for a year and right now is really
hard time to buy real estate so
yeah you know sneaking up on a deal
right now is that gum near impossible
jim's in atlanta georgia hey jim welcome
to the ramsey show
hey how are you doing dave better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm working on my debt snowball i'm
down to my last three debts
and my lowest debt to credit card my
second lowest debt is a 401k
loan and my elastic are a
car lowest i'm wondering if i or
by cheap my lowest balance yeah your
largest amount my largest amount is the
car correct
and you haven't okay so you're down to
your two largest debts
yeah um last one okay all right
just making sure i understand what
you're supposed to say i'm misunderstood
okay good
yep so the my job could be changing
they're shutting down a facility which
means i would either have to find
another job or i'd be pushed into a
relocation
so i'm wondering if in my case i should
just attack that 401k
loan and get it just done what's the
balance i can be agile
um it's about 90 200.
what do you make uh about 112 base and i
usually do
how much of you paid off so far and over
what period of time
uh on for total i've
paid off about twenty three thousand
total on all other debts
how long about 401k i'm sorry how long
did that take uh
it's been about five months okay so in
five months you'll be done
because you only got 20 grand you only
got 20 grand left
well a lot of that was tax refund and
taking savings and dumping into it right
now my burn rate's about two thousand a
month
out of 100 grand um
yeah you need to you need to cut the
lifestyle down dude yeah bro
yeah you're bringing in eight grand a
month how the world are you only seeing
two grand
yeah you you need a little bit more help
uh no more eating out
for you jimbo yeah yeah you need to dial
it back son
and get this knocked out and the faster
you knock it out the less this question
matters
uh and the higher the probability you're
going to get laid off the more the
question matters
so if you've got an 80 chance of getting
laid off yeah maybe you do knock it out
uh but if you're gonna knock it all out
three or four months anyway doesn't
matter much
that's so does that make sense makes
sense this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at ch ministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you can listen to him on the table a
podcast that we put out here at ramsey
network it's also on
youtube and extremely popular be sure
and listen
to the table with anthony o'neil lots of
cool people come to that
table and get all kinds of information
lots of other stuff going on
yeah lots of other stuff dave and we're
going to get you on the table one day we
just got to get you cool first but until
the meantime
until the meantime you gotta catch a
bill battle
it's an uphill battle it might be a long
way but you know until the meantime dave
there was one point in my life i was not
cool i remember being 19 year old 19
years old and i was in tons of debt
uh taking on and taking out student
loans in college
and that was one of the biggest mistakes
i ever made in my life
and i took out student loans dave when
my father actually had the gi bill and i
had a partial scholarship
and i didn't even need them and so i
made some horrible decisions that kind
of wrecked
my financial would you try with that you
didn't buy tuition with it because you
need to
no no no i didn't i got a car stereo
yeah i bought a car stereo i bought the
spinner wheels
uh remember those the wheels when you
stop they kept spinning
that's cause you're cool yeah that's
right that's right that was a
very unwise decision uh but
you know what here's the truth i've
destroyed these student loans
got my life together but you know dave
one of the missions that i'm on is to
really help young people
avoid the mistakes that i've made help
parents help their young people avoid
the mistakes that i've made and we've
all made because we've all made some
financial mistakes and that's why
i have the perfect graduation gift
america
for you to give your high school grad
our team here recently redesigned
rachel and i's book the graduate
survival good
that's not survival good the graduate
survival guide
and look at it i mean it's fire it got
blue the the new look is good you see it
right there
it really does match my shirt they knew
that blue was my favorite
color uh and check this out it's only
ten dollars dave now i was going to talk
to you about this offline because
uh it's normally twenty dollars but they
said that you wanted it ten dollars
and so i'll go with the boss uh but this
is a great deal
so it's graduation season yeah i get it
all these people
you want to charge these poor little
broke graduates too much money hey man
i'm trying to save money so my kids can
go to college
but you're right dave we want to help
them out we want to help them out so for
a limited time
yeah 10 is a great deal so if you want
to get this gift today for any
high school graduate it's good for them
text the word
grad grad to 33789
again that's grad to 33789 and get this
game changing book for only ten dollars
before the prices go back
up to twenty dollars because i'm i'm
rooting for it to go back up but right
now let's take advantage of this giving
season there you go well it's uh
uh buy a case of them because you got it
you're gonna get like 9 000 of those
college or high school graduation
invitations and you need to send them
something that matters
yeah so instead of some stupid little
thing that yeah
that we all got you know remember that
absolutely
i don't even remember it that's how
stupid okay open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five sebastian's up next in
atlanta hi sebastian how are you
hey there dave how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
so i have a quick question for you just
a little background i'm a recent college
grad
working in engineering recently just
landed a job with
a fortune 100 company here local to me
that i plan
to have my full career with i live in
the mountains of north georgia my wife
and i just bought our first home and
hopefully our last we've got some
property and we plan to settle there and
make a life for ourselves but i have 17
000 in student loans
and i am looking to pay those off
hopefully here within the next
six months now my company has just told
me
that they are going to cover all of my
tuition to go back to school
for a promotion to a senior engineering
position my question to you
is should i re-enroll before
or after i pay off those student loans
i'm sorry they're paying for it yeah
they're yeah right
right doesn't matter yeah doesn't cost
you anything
right right now how much how much are
you making there sebastian
right now i'm making about 45. okay and
what are the loans outside of your
student loans do you have what other
kind of debt
i have uh no debt other than home
mortgage that i share with my wife
obviously all of our cars are paid off
i pay for school out of pocket myself
working full-time in college so
it took me a little bit longer but i
graduated with as little debt as i
possibly could
good for you um and i don't have any
credit cards or anything like that is
this
is this 45k home income or just your
income
just mine what what did your wife make
uh actually the exact same
45 so you are doing it by 90k yes
and then is is does she have any debt
uh no debt okay great so yeah man i'm
attacking these you'll be debt free if
y'all live
below your means in three to four months
that's what he said yeah it'd be done in
six months so
i don't understand why it matters when
you register for school since school's
not costing anything
yeah well our uh our loan forbearance as
far as interest goes uh ends in
november so my goal was to attack that
and get that done in six months but
um the tuition program is a
reimbursement program so
100 of that two issue will be reimbursed
oh they're not paying for it until you
pay for it
correct so there's there's the pinch
okay
so what's it cost um
it's looking like it will probably be
somewhere around six thousand dollars a
year
um so what's the first semester you only
need one semester
so three thousand bucks first first
semester will probably be around three
to four thousand dollars okay so let's
do this right
seventeen and three is twenty you make
ninety i don't know why you can't do
both
right
okay are you on the budget right now
sebastian honestly
we are we're actually budgeting pretty
aggressively um i just started this job
actually three months ago okay
um and so we're we're budgeting as if
we're starting from ground zero um
starting as if
if when you when you crunch the numbers
and you're an engineer so you're good
with numbers
if when you crunch the numbers you have
to choose then wait a little bit on
starting the classes yeah
let's get the student loans my one other
option was
wait until the spring semester re-enroll
in the spring semester yeah that's what
i'm saying that's cool
that's what i'm saying but i really
think that it's only three thousand
bucks that's the only pinch
right and that primes the pump and then
they give you three back and you need
that three to pay the next
and then they give you that back and you
need that three to pay then and so once
you got the first three
in you it rolls from there on the
reimbursement program because
assuming they reimburse reasonably quick
yeah
i hear i hear a little bit of stress in
your voice man what's your mortgage
payment uh sebastian
uh i just put him on are you just
putting him a hold okay he's gone but
anyway
but i think the bottom line is is that
um
that may be it you may be onto something
there but but um
yeah let's put actual numbers to the
problem
yeah and not discuss the problem in
theory yeah when you put actual
numbers to math numbers to these
problems
then you really find out if you have a
challenge or not yeah
uh and sometimes that helps me because
then i don't have to think about
the theory but overall if i have to
choose i'm going to be debt free before
i go back
and start cash flowing something i would
in this situation yeah
in this situation i was going to stretch
someday to go get that done in three
months i mean it's about five six grand
a month to get it done
but i see now he has to pay for it out
of pocket yeah
and plus his other bills yeah so but he
could be he could by the time he
you know if you put up the first three
in september and that gets him going and
it's still november
before he gets the student loans paid
off or december before it gets them paid
off that's good that's still good yep
that's that's not a problem for me
because you're still crunching all the
way through it so anywhere in something
like that but
the point being that the actual numbers
are not that's
the the extra 3000 is not what's killing
the deal here
all right robert's with us in
jacksonville florida hey robert how are
you
i'm doing well and how about yourself
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
wonderful thank you for taking my call
um i'm in a little bit of a situation i
don't know what to do
um i have uh some debt myself my home
and no other debt um my father recently
passed away
and i inherited a home in another
how old was state it's a very emotional
thing uh 62
it was due to covert related things so
i'm sorry
yeah it's not not great and i just had a
a child uh three months before he passed
three months after he passed excuse me
um
so i'm trying to figure out what to do
with his home and also his car
and i have no debt personally except for
my mortgage there is a mortgage on his
home
i'll tell you what i want to give you a
good solid answer on this commercial
sneaking up on me
and this is an emotional time so you
hang on for a second we come back from
this break we'll make sure we give you a
good long answer
thanks for hanging out with us
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
this is the ramsey show anthony o'neil
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
we're talking with robert in
jacksonville florida just had a new baby
and sadly his 62 year old dad passed
recently
from covet comp complications he
inherited uh some property
in another state and that's about how
far we got
in the discussion again robert so sorry
for your loss what a horrible thing to
go through thank you
how old are you 32
okay and what did you inherit and what's
your question
so i have the house now there's a
mortgage on it
um i would say i could probably sell it
um for about 450
and there's a 217 thousand dollar
mortgage on it
where uh new york and you're in
jacksonville florida
yes sir okay uh my house here
is um i owe about 98 000. um house
across the street
same house just sold for about 260.
um and i'm going to need to upgrade soon
because of the baby
and we're going to try to have another
one soon um
i have no debt like i said um i have a
comfortable savings
and i have a pretty good income i just
don't know if i should
turn the house in new york maybe into a
rental or
if i should sell it because the market
is going so well
and also i'm not sure if i should buy a
house now because i want to upgrade a
bit because i have
a new child and we're going to have
another one i only have a two-bedroom
house right now
so i need to upgrade a bit um so
and i know that a lot of stuff is
overvalued also
right now you know so they say so i
don't really know what to do
honestly so robert let me let me first
say man again we are
dave and i both are just extremely
apologetic and sorry for your loss
and uh we're praying for you and your
family uh to be sensitive with the
subject
um uh with this uh i think your father
would want you to be wise
i think your father would want you to
not have any stress
uh having a baby uh living
out of the state of new york uh and i
think you should focus first on
in your family so with that being said
um i i think you should
sell the property uh so that way you can
focus solely on you and your family
having a family there
a young family and trying to manage a
rental property way over in new york if
that's going to add on more stress
to you as a father and to your family
and i would say just get a very good
realtor out there go to one of our
programs to help you find
one to help you get the best bang for
your buck and in this market
you probably can get a little bit more
than what it's worth um and quickly
and then take that money and bring it
over to you and your family
but i don't want you to be worth living
in jacksonville uh preparing for you and
your future uh
your family's future and then also
stressing about a home in new york
yeah and here's how we know that that's
good advice
okay the house in new york is gonna
yield you a couple hundred thousand
dollars
after it's sold after mortgage is paid
right
yes sir so if you call me up and said i
have two hundred thousand dollars
sitting in the middle of my kitchen
table
i'm thinking about going to new york to
buy a rental property
you would have never done that that
wouldn't come out that's exactly right
that wouldn't come up
and so um you know the only thing that's
it's just so emotional because it was
your dad's place
and you're trying to think and the real
estate market's whacked right now so
you're trying to figure out how to best
do all that so if i'm in your shoes dude
um i'm gonna cry some i'm gonna go up
there and find some items that
um that he had that
will remind you of him like i've got my
great great grandfather's bible
uh you know i want that kind of stuff
right but i don't care about the house
houses aren't keepsakes and so um
yeah and i would liquidate the car of
the house whatever other miscellaneous
things
and let's bring the cash to florida and
let that be your dad's legacy that he
basically buys his grandkids next house
right and there's no rush to buy the
next house
right you just had the baby i mean you
saw there's not another one here yet and
so
if it takes you a year or a year and a
half to get around to making that next
purchase and getting yours sold
you can delay that decision but i don't
see any reason to delay the one in new
york
um even though it's fully laced
in emotion tori is with us in uh celina
kansas hi tori welcome to the ramsay
show
hello sirs how are you doing today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world
excellent well um so two times in the
last
probably three years i feel like god
has been nudging me to become a nurse
these
the idea of wow i should be a nurse i
shouldn't be doing what i'm doing
has hit me just out of the blue and it
hit me
most recently at a funeral i was at
so and then a little bit of backstory um
the company that i work for i'm actually
one of the owners i'm a shareholder all
that kind of stuff we
do home care and they have graciously
said
that they will pay for me to go through
nursing school because
one of the owners who is you know our
company rn
is is older than i am and going to
retire you know at some point so the
thought is that i would just take
their place when they retire um
i'm calling because i'm very new in my
christian walk and i
have respected you uh for years
and and you know being very god-led
and so i'm wondering you know what i
should do
and how old are you you know the finance
i'm
i'm uh 33. excellent that's a great
question thank you for honoring us with
that
uh question that's sensitive anthony
yeah you know tori i think one of the
things that i hear
from you is uh let me ask this question
real quickly why do you think god is
calling like why are you so passionate
about it why do you think god is telling
you
this is what you need to do other than
what you
may think yeah so
um the first time that it hit me and it
was just it was just like a mental thing
like what are you doing with your life
you're supposed to be a nurse
it was i'm driving on my way to work at
a at a pass job and i saw
a lady in scrubs walking down the street
and then you know i didn't really think
much of it beyond that because
it didn't really apply to me then um but
the one that happened most recently
i was you know at this amazing woman's
funeral
she was actually a client of ours and
you know i was there for support for
family of course and also for
our our caregivers and again you know
no no nursing really related and it just
hit me as i was getting a little bit
emotional about
her granddaughters actually speech at
her funeral
and i was like what am i doing with my
life like this this isn't what i've been
called to do
first and foremost there's not a perfect
system yeah
uh you know and i've been walking with
god a long time and sometimes i find out
it was last night's pizza talking to me
not the holy spirit so um
you just you just don't always know for
sure until you look back right
and you look back and you go well that
was not god it's a disaster back there
and he doesn't he doesn't sign us up for
those or that was god
so i used three or four things uh one
is you need to have a peace when you
start talking about this does your soul
relax the peace that surpasses all
understanding the bible calls it
or do you feel angst if you feel angst
it's probably not god
the second thing i look for is
circumstantial things because god will
align things he runs everything he's
there five years from now
he's there five years ago and he's here
now at the same time he's not bound by
time
and so he's lining things up and you've
got some circumstantial things lining up
here
that make a lot of sense and the third
thing i ask myself is what is this thing
i'm hearing
does it align with scripture
for instance i believe in my study of
the bible for 40 years
that the bible does not say debt is a
good idea
and so if i've got to go into debt to do
it i'm thinking that's not god
because it doesn't align with scripture
or if it involves
uh you doing something else that's you
know more blatantly even against
scripture obviously being a nurse a
caregiver would be a very godly thing to
do
it's a wonderful thing to do so if those
three things are lined up
the only other thing i heard which is
beautiful i know that visiting brand new
babies when they're born
and going to funerals these are the
tuning forks of life
this is when you stop your everyday
grind and you're looking
at a casket or you're looking at a brand
new baby and you get
retuned to the lord retuned
to where god's taking you it's a tuning
fork it sets you back in place
and so the fact that goes down to
funeral home kind of gives me
inspiration too
i think it's him but i don't i could be
wrong we're just talking it through
together
you don't have to get too spooky about
it you can just go be a nurse
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
hey you want to add anything to that how
to hear
god's voice discussion because you you
mean you pastored you
young people you were a youth pastor for
many years yeah i'd be interested to
hear your further take on that we got
pinched by the commercial a little bit
oh yeah dave i think he was hitting it
right on i think one of the things that
you said that resonates with me so well
is when i know i hear from god at least
90
of it is when i can align what i hear
with god's word and what i've learned is
god is really never silent
we're just not listening and when we're
not listening it's because we're not
really
in in the word we're not really studying
and getting connected and getting closer
to him
so for me i tend to say that was god was
in my emotions when i wasn't
really reading but when i'm reading when
i'm when i'm listening
god is talking and when he's silent
that's still god talking
and so for me when you said it has to
align with the word of god
that resonated with me so much because
if i say that i hear something i'm
hearing it through
the word and that's that's that
resonated for me dave
yeah my counsel would be don't move on a
singular
spiritual event right there should be
more than
there should be confirmation in your
spirit confirmation circumstances but
i had a dream and i woke up that morning
and i'm gonna go do it no
no that's a dream yeah well it could it
could be god
right but if it is there's gonna be more
evidence than just that
yes over a period of weeks or months or
years yeah and it may be a timing thing
yeah you know and so uh you know you you
singular events uh
can you're more likely to make a mistake
and miss
whether it's really him or not off of a
singular event but if you can get more
than one data point
as you're walking through that then you
know uh
like you said one another data point is
what it aligns with the word of god
another data point is
the circumstantial thing lined up and
then another and then another time i'm
driving down the street and there's a
lady in scrubs and i hear that
hear this voice again saying this in my
mind and then you know i get that but i
don't uh
come in here after my prayer time
and um in 30 years maybe two times and
say god told me something this morning
we're gonna go do this
ah man we just say you know
okay i'm gonna just pause right here and
make sure that's not last night's pizza
yeah yeah you know i believe from our
our spiritual belief
i mean if god says this is what he wants
you to do he's going to also give you
the resources to do it and he got and he
did he gave him the pain they're paying
for exactly to be a nurse that was
awesome so that's
another big confirmation right there
yeah like hey that
that could be it sounds like god oh
preacher said the definition of
prosperity
is having the money to do what god says
to do yep
and if that's a big thing it gives you
all that if it's a little thing you'll
give you that
yeah that's uh that's a that's a sure
sign that's a great discussion you guys
it's um um in a world called crazy
we need to talk about stuff like this
more yeah and it'll calm some of you
people down some of you people are out
of control out there
oh my gosh calm get off social media
till you grow up
well that just means you won't okay
anyway see there it is all right
ashley's in tampa florida hey ashley
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you what's up
so i have a question that's at the
intersection
of marriage kids and finances
um i
have considered divorce and um
there's a couple of different factors
for that
um a big one is finances
since we've been married we have been in
debt
uh we i don't know if he was in debt
before
i married him but i was in debt i i
wasn't
well i had a small student loan
um that i took care of within the first
few years of our marriage
um anyway we got to about 140 000 of
debt
uh mostly on credit cards and
a lot of different factors went into
that but
there was a point i i was just stressing
me out so much
and um you know i did all the zero
percent refinancing and all that
and um anyway so a few years ago
i listen i'm sorry honey i hate to catch
you off but you're going to tell us what
you need yes
how can we help so i'm considering
divorce
and i guess i wanted to get your
perspective on the best timing for that
there's not good timing for that that's
a horrible thing to have to go through
darling
so and it's due to disagreements over
money
uh and kids and kids
uh what what do you mean about kids
having them or how to treat them or what
yeah i guess bringing them up i'm sorry
i didn't know i was gonna get emotional
it's okay it's fair it's an emotional
thing yeah
and how old are your babies
14 12 and 4.
and so what is he doing about money that
makes you want to end this
so as i said i hadn't started listening
to you a few years ago and so i put
together a budget
and i've been just really hammering on
the debt
i've got it down to about 60 000
without the mortgage where is he why is
he not helping
i have asked him to help i have had
several conversations with him why is he
not healthy
he isn't unwilling
why did you make did you make all the
debt by yourself
no it's been with the family i think i'm
a big factor maybe that's what
i i haven't considered that but uh
no it's just he never said why he won't
help
no he wants me to handle it and then
be involved once the debt is handled why
why it's not logical
he's not given a reason he's just
that was the conversation and how it
ended up is that
i'll handle the debt and then when it's
done
then we'll talk and make plans and stuff
okay um
well obviously that's not a good plan uh
and
is that is that reason enough to end a
marriage no
but is it enough to be upset about yes
and is it an unreasonable process
yes so uh what i would tell you
is this i i um
i think you need someone to guide you
through
this relationship and before you just
slap your hand on the table and say
that's it i'm done
and maybe can guide you through some
tools conversationally to
uh try to draw you guys back together
and to work together
and so what you need is a good marriage
counseling my guess is mister i'm not
involved it doesn't want to go to
marriage counseling either
but you can go without him but you can
go without him and talk to a marriage
counselor who can
hear your whole story long form and
who can injects better wisdom than we
can here
in a five-minute radio call because i'm
definitely not gonna tell somebody
unless there's
domestic violence involved unless you're
getting beat that your marriage is over
on the radio
that would be very unwise of me and very
advised of you to listen to me if i did
do that
but if there's something other than that
you've got some work to do
before you throw down the ultimatum
gauntlet
and sit down with your pastor sit down
with a marriage counselor someone to
guide you through
to where you can say okay i can't stay
anymore
after you've learned how to do this not
from me but i can't stay anymore unless
you're willing to do this with the kids
and this with the money yeah
and whatever this is and you fill in
those blanks
and uh but you've got you've got 15 or
20 years invested in this process
with a 13 year old and so um
you know you want to be very very wise
and very systematic in how you walk
through this
that way you won't it won't be on you
yeah
and i can hear the stress in her her
voice dave and i i want to encourage
everyone who's married out there and if
you're relate you can relate to her
listen to dave advice i mean seek
marriage counseling
even if it's by yourself i can't speak
too much of it because i'm not married
and i've never been in that situation
but we do know that the number one
reason for divorces are finances
and so uh but we could do better at just
getting the council getting the wisdom
before we run
yeah so i mean you'd want to draw out
why you won't get involved and see if we
can solve that yeah
so the other thing we'll do is put you
guys into ramsey plus into
financial peace university again i don't
know if he'll go but
we can help you through the process and
hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
definitely give you that
as a tool hopefully to save your
marriage
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality best-selling author
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple h
five 825 two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five josh is with us to
start off
this hour he's in chicago hey josh how
are you
hey dave it's a pleasure speaking with
you guys hey anthony
uh how are you guys doing great man how
can we help
um hi so i'm started listening to the
show maybe about two months ago so still
relatively new to the process
working through the baby steps i'm on
one step one right now
um more or less my career
i have a job work that pays relatively
well but i'm just not really happy i did
feel like god called me to do
what i'm doing at the time when i got
the job but it's kind of been a very
difficult process
i'm trying to figure out how to work in
possibly looking for an
alternate job into the baby step program
i guess is my question in a nutshell
you mean change jobs while you're
working baby steps
right okay what do you make now
uh right now i'm i make about 50 a year
yeah
5-0 yeah 50 000. yeah and you're how old
at 27. what do you do i'm a biomedical
technician so i
uh repair dialysis equipment okay you
know what
and what would you change too
that kind of becomes a little bit of a
the thing like
so i'm a very social person and i i very
much so enjoy
speaking with people and the kind of
work that i do now is very socially
isolating so it uh i guess the the
easiest answer is it doesn't bring joy
to my heart to do what i'm doing now
even though i know i'm helping people so
i want to find something that i'm able
to
invest into others
yeah that's pretty broad yeah i don't
know where you put that resume in
right now you you got to be intentional
and and it doesn't sound like you're
being intentional so
uh no i don't think it's a good opportu
it's a good time for you to change
careers
now let's just say this all right you
need to go through ken coleman's process
right
yeah and once you do that and you
identify i want to work
doing i want to be one of those whatever
that is
or something that has these components
to it
whatever that's a little more than just
i don't want to work with machines i
want to work with people i get that
that's a
but but that does that leaves the entire
world open that you could do
there's a lot of stuff you can do out
there that that with that as your
guidelines so you're going to have to
get more clarity
on where you're going number one and you
can do that while you're working to get
out of debt
and once you know what that is then we
gotta figure out what that pays now
here's the deal
if it pays fifty thousand dollars a year
or more
and you can land the job it doesn't harm
your debt snowball at all as a matter of
fact it helps it for you to make the
move
if it pays thirty thousand dollars a
year and you make fifty now now we gotta
stop and think about it maybe not
but if it's a lateral or up move why
wouldn't you
yeah a lot of the jobs that i've been
looking at would be uh
not not as high of an income you know
why because you don't have it clarified
you haven't set a goal you just kind of
generally went i want out of here and
who's hiring well who's hiring his entry
level always
so we need to have a little bit better
clarity on your career path and this
might take six months
for you to land a better job but but
you're not gonna die there in six months
i mean you're just you just need to see
some human beings is all you're saying
and you'll get there you're gonna be
fine what we don't want to sign up for
is 10 years of doing this and doing
nothing about it
right right but 10 10 months you can
survive while you find the right clarity
uh but no i don't want you moving down i
want a matter of fact even if you were
out of debt and you just called and went
i think i want to be happy
good move up that's that makes you
happier
if they if you found something paid 100
000 with people involved you'd be a lot
happier
very much so yeah so let's do that i
mean why do we have to make the
assumption that in order to be happy we
have to make less money
it generally works the other way around
by the way but you know what dave this
younger generation
really they will prefer happiness over
making good
but they're not independent they're not
on the same spectrum
unhappy or happy does not mean broke
[Laughter]
it's not it doesn't mean you have to
make less to be happy that is true
you don't you don't have to do that you
can just find a different way to do the
thing that makes you happy
that the society will pay you for yeah
i'm not saying money makes you happy but
a hundred thousand is a lot easier to
work with
than 30. absolutely i agree with you
trust me i'm talking about this on my
show i know i'm saying i know it's just
but it
can run coleman runs into this all the
time i'm gonna i want to have work that
has meaning
and great so get some work that has
meaning help a whole bunch of people and
get paid a lot
exactly you know i got i have work that
has meaning i'm doing pretty good
sure me too we're helping a lot of
people so it's you know you don't have
to
be broke to be happy that or or work for
a non-profit which by the way is not a
biblical construct
that is an irs guideline every
non-profit
is profitable or they close
they go broke it's an accounting
entry it's not a holiness factor
there's no such thing you can't you know
i'll guarantee you man the the uh the
doctor that you go see
is in in and it brings healing to your
life is as much a ministry as your
preacher
so good i mean it's just that that's
work
is worship when done with the right
motives and when you're serving and
helping people
so uh this this idea that you have to
work for some entity
to be holy no it's the work you do and
how you do it in the spirit you do it
with and by the way if you help a whole
bunch of people
as our friend says they will give you
certificates of appreciation with
presidents faces on them i love that
rabbi daniel lapin in the book thou
shall prosper one of our buddies says
that all the time
yeah so it's a great question it's a
great question so what we want to do
in your case josh is attack the
construct that you're dealing with
which made you call and say i think i
need to make less to be happy
and should i do that on the debt
snowball no you shouldn't
you should go make more and be happy and
then you don't even have to ask the
question
yeah i agree go to kencoleman.com
download uh
some of his materials there's lots of
stuff there free yeah it'll get you
going he's got the seven stack
steps the first one is to get clear yeah
the seven
stages of working and finding the dream
job the first ones get clear clarity and
you don't have that yet josh
yeah all you know is you don't like
where you are you don't know what you
like and i recommend josh take some time
call into his show tomorrow
yeah he'll help you walk through the
process real quickly on his show so go
to kencolemanshow.com
uh look at the hours there within your
city give it give us a call
he'll probably be more gentle than i was
yeah a lot more that's why i didn't say
too much but
kim would take kim would take real good
care of you uh bro
call him tomorrow he'll even give you a
copy of the book just tell him dave and
anthony said
you'll give us a call oh we can give him
a copy yes
all right why don't you think so don't
you think so thank you being for nice
dave yeah well you're you're the nice
guy you brought it up
yeah proximity principle number one best
seller by ken coleman on helping you get
a job and your thing you love
kelly's gonna give joshua yes since i
was mean to him thank you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
hey folks have you ever made a dumb
decision with zeroes on the end because
you didn't do your research
yeah me too most people make choices
based on feelings
or opinions especially when buying a
house
but when it comes to this real estate
market feelings are not your friends
facts are your friends so check your
facts
find out what you can actually afford
research what's trending in home prices
talk to a reputable real estate
agent in your area someone who's done
real estate a lot when a market is white
hot like this a monkey can sell a house
it does not all you just put a sign yard
people line up
but that doesn't mean you sold it for
the most you could get
because you don't have any idea what the
flip you're doing you and your monkey
you know really you need to put a sign
in the yard with a pro who sells 50 60
houses a year
and did last year and knows what they're
doing and they know how to handle
this white hot market and you'll get the
most possible dollars
for your house it's not amateur hour out
there right now people
although there's a bunch of amateurs out
there
never buy a house without the facts go
to ramsey solutions.com
agent find an endorsed local provider in
your
area that will help you make smart
decisions these are people we have
vetted
they have not only the heart of a
teacher not only believe in the ramsey
principles
but they also sell a ton of houses they
know what they're doing
ramsey solutions.com
agent reggie's in chattanooga hey reggie
what's
thank you for taking my call dave and
hello to you your guests there
got a question for you my daughter is 24
years old
i would like to know what can i do
financially to put money away from her
and potentially grandkids should that
happen
so that they will have a much easier
time or be better off
when she finally gets to my age or older
if the lord allows that's such a great
question
uh reggie um well where are you at
financially right now
oh i'm following your steps i gotta i
gotta i have a ways to go i have some uh
realignment
that i need to do okay so so you still
have some debt right now
no i don't we don't have any i don't
have any debt okay
houses paid for uh just bumped up the
company 401 to the 15
um what else is there on that list
um yeah you got some money put away okay
so you see
so cool great
i just wanted to make sure because i
think i wanted to make sure that you are
good
because the first thing that you can do
i believe as a parent
is to make sure that you're in a healthy
place to when you do get older and you
will need some help from your children
you're not putting them in an
uncomfortable place financially and have
given them extra financial
responsibility so that's the first way
to give your child a head start is to
make sure that you are good you and your
spouse if you're married or good
financially
um on number two dave you're living this
season out right now you know preparing
to uh pass down some wealth and legacy
to your kids what is one key thing
that we all can do to really set our
young people up successfully financially
down the road
if they can't make it on their own
they're not gonna make it when you leave
them money
well that is true but if you train them
up the correct way it's not going to be
an issue she's
she's she's out of college okay she has
a master's she has a bachelor's
it's just a matter of uh opportunity
so that's not an issue you know so she's
she knows how to work
she knows how to give she knows how to
save she doesn't spend and as
she if she can handle her life and her
money well
and she won't need you because she's
doing a great job with her life and with
her money she won't need wealth from you
that's when she's best prepared to
actually receive wealth from you
yeah that's i i understand that but i
would like to have something there other
than what i'm putting away from myself
and my wife
why that's what you know in other words
go be a millionaire
how old are you i am 50
i if the lord allows and i make it to
the end of this month
i'll be 54 years old okay cool well the
average millionaire in our study it took
him 17 years so when you're 70 you
should be a millionaire
what do you make
about right now about 36
your wife work she does what she meant
she's
right around the same okay she got a 75
000 70 000
household income cool great no debt work
our baby steps man and in 15 years
you're gonna be in a really good
position to leave her
maybe not a million dollars maybe three
quarters of a million
um that you're living on and then when
you pass
you can pass it to her assuming she has
the character to handle it but if you
pass money to somebody that doesn't have
the character to handle it
it's not a blessing it's a curse yeah
yeah so you taking care of you anthony
said it right
right out of the gate you taking care of
you and not being a burden is step one
you taking care of you and becoming
wealthy
and then leaving that whatever however
you want to define wealthy
i don't care if it's 200 000 or 2
million i mean anywhere in there is
going to be good with me
and you leave that to her and it
supplements her life
because she already has her act together
that's when you've done your job man
but there's no magic thing you can buy
that just drops a bomb of money on her
and makes her everything okay
uh there's no such thing yeah
and i like how you said that dave
there's no magic think
it's just discipline it's following the
baby steps
and when you hear dave say go out there
and you become a millionaire
what dave is is saying on top of that
it's like hey when you build wealth
uh you're building wealth not just for
you but you better leave that to your
kids
and they'll be able to maybe invest that
leave that to their kids but you can't
go out here build a little bit for you
and your wife and then also build wealth
for them
it's not your responsibility to build
wealth for your kids it's your
responsibility for you and your wife to
build
wealth live and enjoy your life and then
once you pass
you can pass that down to whomever you
choose
and that's the main thing that i think
we have to really focus on yeah
ourselves yeah and and here's the thing
these things all go together because
when you get a big pile of money
regardless of where you get it from
all it does is magnify your life all
your weaknesses
are going to be exposed in spades
they're going to be everywhere
all your strengths are going to become
superpowers
your good parts are going to get bigger
and your bad parts are going to get
bigger money
magnifies that's why when somebody is a
doofus
and they win the lottery they become a
doofus on steroids
yes and that's what you see out there
and this is the problem your life is not
fixed by more money
your life is magnified by more money and
so reggie that's true for your daughter
that's my point so if she takes this
wonderful job she's done getting this
education
getting her master's degree all the
stuff that make you so proud i mean you
can hear his chest sticking out when
he's bragging on his baby there that's
awesome
and then she throws her shoulders back
and leans in goes and has a big time
career
starts making some money controlling her
life not it gets out of debt or
stays out of debt builds some emergency
funds builds her long
time investing her long-term investing
uh that's setting her up her living her
life properly
is the best indicator that whatever you
leave her is going to be a blessing and
not a curse and i actually prefer
that dave than actually getting a
million dollars i would prefer to see my
daughter my son
with the wisdom and knowledge and making
uh good decisions with their money being
good stewards of their money
then for them to be horrible with their
money and then i leave them with my
money that i worked hard here's the
interesting thing is when you're leaving
that money it's going to go away
if they can't handle it right and if
they have those skills they'll go get
their own million dollars and then when
you add to it
now we're fixing the next generation
come on dave i like that
so it really doesn't kind of land in the
middle if you leave a doofus a million
dollars they're gonna lose it
you know man dave you just said
something can we repeat that again you
said
dad gets a million she gets a million
when dad passes
that million goes on top and that's two
million pass it down to the kids that's
three million that's
that's legacy dave yeah this is changing
your family
look at them young people out there
smiling he holding her real tight like
baby let's do this
that's how it works this is how it works
right here oh
i love it i like that one this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
two two 825-5225 chris and jess are in
rochester new york it says on my screen
you guys are debt free congratulations
thank you thank you well done how much
you pay off
107 hundred dollars in twenty months
excellent how long i'm in and what was
your range of income during that time
we started about 140 000 and finished
about 150 000.
cool what do you guys do for a living
i'm a mechanical engineer i'm a project
manager
very good excellent careers great
and 108 000 of what kind of debt
well it was mostly made up of student
loans because this was my
second career um but then we had a
couple cars
some stuff like a furniture mattress
things like that and then just a little
bit of credit cards
ah so you guys were fairly normal
we were very normal it was super
uncomfortable yeah normal sucks
so uh how long y'all been married
six years since august six years wow so
about two years ago
something happened what lit the fuse on
this
yeah so um a little over two years ago i
i lost a job and it put me in a real
real bad place and i didn't know where
to go and i remember conversations with
jess about
hey how are we gonna how are we gonna
pay for the house like you know i or
maybe we're gonna have to sell it
and then um i found found a great place
to work
um and i met someone there at work who
said hey you should
you should listen to dave ramsey and i
said sure
and he he gave me your podcast to listen
to i listened to it while on a work trip
and i came back home and i said hey
honey
i think i think we have a good plan for
us to not fight about money anymore whoa
some money fights have been there huh
it was it was strained i i was a
financial person and he just didn't
really understand
everything that i was doing i was i was
kind of one of those like credit card
points
people you know i was really into my my
my points and my
my airline miles and things that you
talk about um
and after he came home and told me about
you and and showed me the podcast
i was like yeah 100
let's do it you know i i'm very excited
to be out of debt
and if you're on the same page with me
like i'll do anything you know
let's follow this wow so it is
interesting that
his job loss resulted of course in
getting a better job but
also resulted in scaring the pants off
of you
yes it did oh yeah i mean
like your heart your heart was ready in
a special way
you know the pandemic did that for a lot
of people it scared the crud out of them
and they're they're like okay never
again never had their never again moment
in 2020 you know i don't want to be here
when the big bad wolf comes and blows
unless i'm in the brick house
you know and so i got to get my act
together and that's what y'all did i'm
so proud of you way to go
thank you so much it feels you you feel
uh
strong don't you it's an incredible
feeling like the
financial piece that that you talk about
all the time it's
it's almo it's so much weight off of
your shoulders that
you know right now we're going through a
hard time personally but the one thing
that we don't have to worry about right
now is our finances they're so strong
that
you know it's it's just like carry on
with the rest of the stuff the other
curveballs that you get in life
you know you can handle them now that
we're on the same team
and we've got such a good strong footing
financially you can
you know look my son in the eye and say
hey you know i know you're going to be
okay
like i know i know you're going to be
okay and i think that's um that's a big
reason why
why we did this yeah so jess i'm curious
what would you say
over the last 20 months was the hardest
thing
for you all to do to pay off 107
000 in debt
um i think we had a really rough time in
the beginning about budgeting
that uh you know we we had to understand
you know what gazelle intense was for us
and what that meant
and what a need versus a want was and i
think it was hard for us to just say
like
hey these are the things that are
definitely wants and really identify
those
and come up with a budget for each one
of our budget items and
sit down agree upon it and that that
really strengthened
our relationship and and really set us
up to be able to accomplish this goal
oh man i love it i love it so who who
was hardcore
and who was a little lighter so we're
both nerds i think it's probably the
fair
the fair comment here so we're both
looking at the spreadsheet and we're
like well do we
do we really need to do this like can we
can we wait we both had moments where
we wanted to spend a little extra money
doing something and the other one would
give the look and say hey
i don't i don't think we can do that you
know i'm still going to say it was me
i'm still going to say i was a little
bit more hardcore yeah i was i was about
to agree with you jess
that sounds like jess was the hard one
yeah she was already the points queen so
we just converted her to
being the head gazelle yeah that's cool
you guys are both incredible i'm so
proud of both of you very very well done
so cool so you mentioned that you guys
have struggles and was it your son
so um we'll be honest we're expecting
another
um and it's a little complicated and so
it's it's okay everything's going to be
fine but
it's just going to be harder than we
thought it was going to be um and that
kind of moted uh
motivated us even further to get out of
debt faster and so we made
some extra gazelle decisions uh
based on like that circumstance um but
we have a great support system
we have in we're almost done with our uh
our
baby step three and so we're ready you
know we're ready to
you know and here's another reason
you're ready
is that for the first time in six years
or in a you in
at another level not maybe for the first
time in six years but at another level
you have fought the dragon together
yeah yes yeah and this is yet one more
dragon to fight
this uh the challenge the challenge that
you've got in front of you
and when you can lock arms and beat the
money dragon you can lock arms and beat
the next one
that's the plan it's a tough road ahead
resiliency is
you know it's it's a really big deal
yeah i'm sure it is and financial
resiliency really leads to everything
else yep your life
yeah but the the teamwork that you
developed on the money thing was a
just a warm up for the next thing right
that's it
yeah we can interlock arms and know that
whatever challenges are going to come
our way we know that we can overcome
them
and we just got to focus and knock it
out amen amen i'm proud of you guys
you're heroes this is beautiful
very well done sorry for what you're
facing but i think you're up to it
and uh yeah you got it you got it yeah
you're gonna be you're gonna be fine
it's gonna be all right
all right very cool all right last thing
what advice do you give to someone
uh who just lost their job but then they
got another job and they got the pants
scared off
and they said i need to do something
what's the key to getting out of debt
to me it's listen to the wake-up call
there's a reason you got it
answer the call listen listen to the
call and say what do i need to do
differently today
to make sure that this is not going to
happen to me again and not going to
knock me down on my knees again
what can i do to look at this i know i
got this touchdown
that was probably the best one i've
heard in a while that's good yeah
jess what about you um
just more realistically is hey you know
follow the budget have meetings get
on the same page understand your needs
versus your wants and take it one step
at a time
you don't get all this information just
keep going i'm sorry
that's exactly perfect excellent did
y'all get all the information just from
the podcast or you picked up the book or
you went to fp financial peace
university or what
yeah so uh all of those
we did purchase totally makeover we read
we read through it got real excited
about it
went to nfu class coordinated an fu
class oh wow
um and we're we're you know we're a hook
line and sinker and
all the whole work so it's really a
great plan and we're glad to share that
with
everybody we we know i think yeah we
want to shout out to our
parents and and our friends who inspire
us and we inspire them and
and uh you know so everything's been
super positive with it
well done well thanks for coordinating
the class we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because that's for sure
what you're doing you're
building and leading your legacy we're
also going to send you another copy of
the total money makeover
uh for you to pay it forward and give it
to somebody who's right at the beginning
of where you were just
24 months ago chris and jess in
rochester new york 108 000 paid off in
20 months making 140 to 150
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
that's how it's done that's how it's
done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today pam's in charleston south
carolina hey pam what's up
good afternoon um i'm calling with a
question regarding
my home equity loan and i hope i don't
get too emotional on you
my husband passed away i did it last
year
very sudden and from the day he was
diagnosed with cancer to death was five
and a half weeks
wow how old how old was he sick
and all 62. oh my goodness
how long you all married we were six
weeks shy of 40 years
40 years about like sharon and me oh my
gosh girl i'm so sorry
yes thank you um
we were both employed at the same
corporation
i received survivor benefits um the only
debt
i have is a 40 000 home equity loan we
own our house outright we own our cars
outright
no credit card debt no other debt at all
other than the equity loans it's at
two and a half 2.25 interest
my question is should i invest the
survivor's benefit towards um
how much was it retire i'm um i've gotta
write about 170 thousands okay did you
guys have any other nest egg
not yet no okay and you're 62. so
did you have a pension plan with that
company
yes i actually just retired last monday
i went ahead i could not handle going
into work anymore because
we drove in together every day we ate
lunch together every day
and it was just too difficult so what is
your
what is your what does your retirement
income look like
um i'm going to be receiving um my first
pensions will start at the end of this
month
and i will be getting about 5 000 an
annuity
um i have not declared uh social
security income yet
i will start that and your income not
counting social security is going to be
5 000
a month correct and what did you used to
make when you were working
i made 72 000. he made about 75 000.
okay so you're going from 150 000
household income to a 60 000 household
income plus
social security correct
can you budget and live on that
correct you can
i think you can but can do you think you
can
oh i'm sure i can we had already
actually started because
i had been talking about wanting to
retire in a year or two
so starting back in january we actually
started living as if we were only making
one income
yeah and we were handling it
um i probably have about
um outside of the
survivor's benefit i probably have about
30 000 in the bank
okay how many cars do you have
two i'm going to be selling one how will
it bring
it's a 2013 so
just afford um focus
i mean i don't know what do you think it
is five thousand dollars
probably five thousand yes okay all
right okay
all right here's a couple of things
your heart's broken mind with you
something happened to sharon i would be
just like you i wouldn't be able to
breathe real good
and you're still trying to catch your
breath don't make
big scary decisions
when you're having trouble breathing in
the fog
of grief okay
okay give yourself some space to just
cry
you don't have to be a professional
investor
you certainly don't need to listen to
anybody on some investment thing of any
kind
right now you don't need to
uh buy anything big
to try to make you feel better grief
spending is a real thing um
and yes i would pay off the home equity
loan that's not a big decision that's
not a big problem
so you're going to have 150 000 uh 170
minus 40. you have 130 left to put
into investments later make sure you
have an emergency fund you already have
that that's 30 000 it's gonna have 35
000
with car so you're okay kid you're fine
you're in good
shape but there's nothing you have to
prove
but you do have to live on that income
not touch it
not touch the nest egg that's left
beyond paying off this mortgage right
that'll make it easier to live on the
income because you don't have the
mortgage anymore the heloc anymore
and you do have to promise that i'm not
going to go spend 100 000
on something or some neighbor or kid
or nephew shows up and needs 50 grand
you're not the source
okay i just should just pretend like you
don't have any money
and and give yourself six months to cry
put that money in a cd don't do anything
with it
after whatever's left after the home
after you pay off the home equity loan
get to get yourself on a budget and and
no grief spending and no big time
sophisticated investing
just take your time give yourself some
room yeah
just like you couldn't drive to work
just like you couldn't show up and not
eat lunch there
just like all that this stuff's gonna
still hit you for a little while i mean
you were married 40 years
and you're hurting yeah and that makes
you human it makes you a good wife
pam here's another thing i would add on
top of what dave is saying because he's
giving you all the practical information
that that i love so awesome job on that
dave um
next thing i would just say why are you
taking this time make sure you make sure
you have a good community around you you
know a good community a family good
community of church
uh just give me good a good community
that can encourage you
give you wise counsel and just walk
through this next season of your life
because this you're going to be feeling
like this for at least the rest of this
year yeah and um i think that good
friends
who can hold you and help you uh
make the wise decisions and remind you
that hey this this could be an emotional
decision let's back up
let's go do something else productive
before you make this decision
because community is important yeah
that's true also we're going to sign you
up for ramsey plus for a year
and let you go through financial peace
university there's good community there
it'll give you something to lay your
hand to now that you're retired
and you can you can jump in there and
start learning about that to give you
something to put your
your mind on so it doesn't just cycle on
all this
and um you know and it'll give you a
sense of confidence
about the decisions you make with money
going forward
because you'll be more knowledgeable so
we're going to pay for all that it's our
gift to you
we're christians and the bible's real
clear we're to take care of widows
and we love you we're sorry you've gone
through this and
we'll do anything we can to help you
call us back anytime we're here
here to help so um
some of the worst decisions i've seen
financially made by people anthony over
the years
is within six months
of loss of a long-term spouse or of a
child
somebody will do some serious
dumb spending and um
and and you know the interesting thing
was i've seen it happen
even with my personal friends over the
years and they're people that
otherwise were real level-headed but
stuck
in this waves of
fog of grief or whatever whatever you
want to use waves of grief coming at you
crashing on you
um i mean you're just going along okay
and then i'll suddenly start crying
yeah you know everything's fine and then
i see some
some bush out in the yard that reminds
me you start crying
and uh and that is not a time to be
making big decisions and i i've
um because then you compound
you look up two years later and you've
got two things to grieve
yeah the loss and then the the bad
decisions
yeah and so just slow down as much as
you can
make as few decisions as possible and
that's what we were outlining for pam
and
um i mean she's going through a real
thing there that's
so so tough very but um we're here for
you kiddo
you call us anytime we'll walk with you
or answer your questions and you're now
plugged into ramsey plus you've got
coaches available
community available classes available
the every dollar budget app there is to
there to help you and get you going and
all of that
all of that will get you going
that puts this hour the ramsey show in
the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
can be intentional about your character
you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you can get in if you dial
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
rick is in san antonio to start off this
hour hi rick how are you
i'm doing fine dave thanks for taking my
call my wife and i love listening to
your show
well thank you sir how can we help well
she retired after 32 years in the
military
a few years ago and we have
a she has a retirement income of about 6
500
a month growth and out of that we pay a
421 dollar
survivor benefit plan which is the
annuity to protect her retirement
uh in case she passes then i would
receive 55
of that amount now we're thinking that
we have an opt-out where we can
we're in a period of time we can we can
stop it
and take that money instead and pay off
our house it's the only thing that we
owe
we owe about 140 000 on it and
um we're wondering if we should do that
or continue and just pay the
house out of uh for a part-time income
and i'm a seasonal tax preparer
so if you uh you're paying for
uh okay i see what you're doing all
right so your income will agree it's
about four
minutes basically what it is yeah i got
it i'm i'm familiar with it i was just
trying to remember
how they did it okay um
all right so you you're how old
i'm 60 and she is 60 as well
uh 50th okay tell her thanks for her
service by the way
um kids are grown and gone uh yeah
that's for the only ones in the house
okay all right
and so if she passes away and the
annuity passes with
her because you cancelled this benefit
uh what is your income what are you
living on
um basically off of our retirement uh we
have about
850 000 in uh retirement funds
and 50 000 in cash i mean i would just
continue to work part-time and
uh until social security kicks in
way to go millionaire
pretty stinky cool man well we're
thinking that we
should probably get to opt out of that
and just yes you should opt out
you should opt out of it okay okay okay
if someone does not have 800 000 around
i might have used a little bit of it to
buy some term insurance to make sure
you're okay if she passes
but you're okay if she passes
financially speaking
you're you're not okay but i mean
financially you'll be okay yeah
financially
yeah yeah yeah so i figure that we'll be
all uh all right and she's
her big deal is after 32 years she just
didn't want to see it go away if she
passes early because she just needs to
stay alive
[Laughter]
you know she's a breast cancer survivor
so she thinks she has bad genes and
she's not sure but
you know that but i'm trying to convince
you we could probably give it up and be
okay
i i would give it up where i in your
shoes this is basically insurance
and yourself you're in a position of
being self-insured yeah
that makes sense yeah if you really want
to be uber
conservative go buy a half million
dollars in term owner
um how long ago was the breast cancer
uh it's been about 10 years yeah she can
get a half million dollars in term and
you'll be surprised at how cheap it is
is xander insurance
i wouldn't do that but if that makes her
feel better it's going to be a lot less
than 480
a month a whole lot less and you can
still turn and get the house paid off
and yeah you need to pay off the house
this week out of that
out of that 800 as well didn't even ask
how much it was but you probably need to
pay it off this week
so yeah very interesting well done
good stuff yeah i mean that they
uh survivor benefit 6 500 a month is a
wonderful retirement for the military
it is that's nice it's really nice she
spent some some good time
i need to talk to my dad and see how
much he's getting he retired
why you think you're going to get
stronger i'ma get something it's my dad
no no you're not either i know him
he's a smart man he's gonna look at you
he's just gonna look at you when you say
that
look at you like why are you asking that
never hurt to ask amanda's with us in
tucson arizona
hey amanda welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much dave thanks for taking
my call
yeah my question for you today
i am active duty military
and my husband and i are wondering if we
should plan to buy
within the next year or so or if we
should wait
to buy we've been renting for eight
years now
and we don't really desire to live long
term and concern
we prefer to be on the east coast but my
husband is pursuing
prerequisites for med school or pa
school currently
and we just want to try limiting moving
our family moving our kids
but we're getting i'm getting kind of
tired of renting
but we don't see ourselves in tucson
long term
yeah before i answer this question i i'm
curious why do i hear people say they're
tired of renting
why are you tired of renting
well i think because we've rented for
eight years now i'm 33 years old
we're on baby step 3b okay
and just feel ready we're
ready to kind of take that next step
we're debt-free
like you feel like you're wasting money
am i correct
in some ways yes and we just um
we started doing some investing in
retirement
over the last couple years but i just
feel like we're pulled
and we just had our third baby so we
just bought a
a minivan in cash which was so exciting
um but yeah just wanting to limit
uprooting the kids from school but also
i think you know the answer yeah i think
you know the answer that
you're still in in a position of
transition which is not a good time to
buy no
yeah and you're not making a bad
decision by renting because you're in
baby step 3b
now dave correct me if i'm wrong i don't
have a problem with you actually
investing and still saving to go to war
as a home yeah so i would say go ahead
and go over to babysit number four go
ahead and start investing
15 and starts continue
saving for a home so that way when you
all do
um get out of the military or at least
get into 20 yeah when he finishes pa
school and you land where you're going
to land
yeah and and you're sitting down roots
that's when you buy
and you already knew that didn't you
okay i did i just feel like i'm getting
to the point in life where
it would be nice okay yeah your point of
life when you're ready to get a home is
when you're going to be there a little
while
right and you've settled in after this
pa thing this house could if you bought
a house right now
and then he ends up moving to a
different city to do pa school or
do his fellowship or do whatever any of
that stuff this house is going to be an
anchor around your neck not a blessing
just like it would have been every time
they moved you in the military
that's why we tell folks in active duty
when they're being moved all the time
don't be buying a home because you end
up with a home in every city you're
stationed in
pretty much and you can't get rid of
them and so yeah you're
i appreciate your frustration and i
appreciate your
you know ready i'm ready to put down
roots you know but you got really one
more step
to do that and that's the transition
after pa school and after the military
and you're going to be there it's not
going to be there in a heartbeat won't
be that long
kids are going to be fine you've done a
good job you're winning
you're staying out of debt you bought
the minivan with cash rockstar
good stuff this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you probably get a lot of financial
advice these days some of it's bad some
of it's just plain
confusing so-called experts using big
fancy words to sound smart but they
never really
explain what they mean and may not even
know what they mean learning about money
should not be this complicated
it doesn't have to be complicated it's
not complicated
that's why we created ramsey plus we
break down the financial topics that are
important to you
so you can tackle whatever you're facing
right now
with ramsey plus you get our best
digital courses including financial
peace university
all the tools you need to start feeling
confident with your money
including the world's best budgeting app
every dollar you'll even get help with
the super confusing business of filing
your
taxes that's right ramsay plus is now
offering a free
federal classic e-file with ramsey smart
tax
an easy and secure way to get your taxes
done right without the stress
money can make sense and you
can do this to start your free trial of
ramsey plus
text trial to 33 789
text trial 233
789 our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal so
dave today question comes from joshua in
the most beautiful state i believe
california
the beautiful sunny california his
question is
my parents want me to go to college when
i graduate high school this year
they have saved fifty thousand dollars
in the 529 plan and i would have to take
out loans to fund anything
over that amount i want to go to
culinary school which would only cost
forty five thousand dollars
leaving five thousand dollars for one of
my siblings to use
what should i do well number one
let's take out you're gonna have to take
out student loans we're gonna take debt
off
of the table that's number one number
two
um i would honestly have a conversation
uh joshua with your parents and asking
them what's your game plan
for your stu for your siblings is this
529 for all of you all
or can you use all 45 of it if you can
then you're going to school 100
debt free but i would definitely have a
conversation with your parents
to see exactly what was their game plan
if they're only giving you 20
000 of that but if they're saying no you
can use all 50
and we'll worry about your siblings
because we have another 529 for them or
another game plan
then you're gonna take out the forty
five thousand dollars go to culinary
school and before i choose this
particular culinary school
i'm gonna do my research and make sure
that that's the most affordable one
uh within my price range yeah
so um i have several chefs joshua that
are
uh award-winning you've seen some of
them on tv
that are friends of mine as a matter of
fact i was with one of them last night
that was won several awards
and um i don't know anything about
culinary except i'm good at eating it
um and i'm really good at that it's i'm
like a professional
um it's like my favorite sport and so i
like hanging out with these guys
uh but one thing i have noticed about
them is
uh that the ones that make substantial
money
are few and far between
a lot of culinary school graduates don't
end up being chefs they end up being
cooks
and sous chefs for a long time waiting
on their break
to be the chef um
and it's in a hot kitchen and it turns
out it's really hard work
making beautiful gourmet tasty
food i think i need to take a break
right now and um
but yeah it's uh but it's really hard
work
and it's not a um you know
50 of the graduates of culinary school
do not make uh great money
they end up uh you know cooking
somewhere
uh which you can do by the way without
culinary school right uh
so you need to have gotten your fingers
into that business a little bit i'd love
for you to spend this summer in a
kitchen somewhere uh
if you can sous chef great if you can
just do prep work or something that's
great but i want you to get in there and
feel the heat of those stoves and the
sweat
and i want you to listen to the [ __ ]
customers
and i want you to experience what it's
going to be like doing
what you're talking about doing before
you make this choice i'm not saying you
should not go to culinary school
i'm saying that television has
romanticized it
to the point that i'm a little bit
afraid of you having an unrealistic
expectation of exactly what you're
stepping into sir
yeah so go in that kitchen sweat and
chop some asparagus spears for a little
bit
and figure out if this really what you
want to do before you invest your entire
saving your parents savings
for higher education on this i would do
that i'd say that about a lot of
different things
by the way if it had been unfairly
romanced
by television yeah yeah and so
uh you know that's where i would tell
you to go on it
is uh and it is not as glamorous
as it looks like when gordon ramsay's
yelling at somebody
and his is spelled s-a-y by the way the
number of times he and i are confused is
unbelievable but um anyway
it's not only spelled different he has
great hair i don't have any
he yells i don't much i was about to say
uh
let's talk about that offline dave
sam is in santa fe new mexico hey sam
welcome to the ramsey show
how you doing mr ramsay and mr o'neill
it's an honor to talk to you guys
you too sir how can we help
i'm i'm in engineering school right now
and i
um i lost my internship at the first
part of the year
due to you know covet slowdowns and
stuff like that
so i ended up having to take out a
student loan
in the in the first part of last year
um i'm sorry the first part of this year
and
it's uh nine thousand dollars and i i
just got
a new internship that i'll start next
week
and it's a 30 bump and pay
and i was wondering should i use that
30 percent to cash flow next semester
yes which is my graduating semester or
pay off the debt no cash flow you next
semester man get through college
don't worry about 9 000 right now i wish
you would have called this
uh before you made that decision i'll be
able to walk you through that process
but that's there we can't go backwards
that's cool uh but the next thing is we
want to make sure this 9000 doesn't turn
into 18 000.
all right so cash flow it get through
college
uh 100 uh without borrowing no more
money and
pile up as much cash as you can yeah in
the process that 30 percent included if
you don't need that 30 percent
i want you to graduate college always
still be in the bank after you land the
new job when you land the new job you
got that money laying there
that'll jump start towards the nine
right yes
yes sir but let's hold it as an
insurance policy yeah let's hold it as
an insurance policy through graduation
and through the first apartment okay
yes sir the insurance policy is a to
ensure graduation be
ensure graduation debt free yes yeah so
first goal
do no more harm yeah second goal clean
up the debt
yep good stuff very good stuff yeah a
lot of people are
you know it's uh because if you
in your he's not going to do this but
sometimes we get the same question
it's like you know do i pay off the
student loan and then turn around take
out another one to go next semester no i
mean you'd be better off just to pay
you're swapping dollars you're swapping
pockets right you'd be better off to
just pay it and
pay your way through and then go back
and address the student loan later don't
swap pockets
uh he's not he's not got that exact
situation because he sounds like he's
got a track
all the way out debt-free and that's a
good plan so
uh and then this extra money should
still be laying there
yeah i sure hope so sure hope that's the
way it works out for him that's good
good stuff real good stuff i i like that
question man
i mean thanks for thanks for calling and
asking because we need to remind the
people
moving forward hey listen don't pile up
anymore dead stay away from it
yeah exactly anthony o'neil ramsey
personality my co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five debbie
is in columbus ohio
hi debbie welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call
my honor how can we help
i just got done paying thirty one
thousand eight hundred and forty six
dollars
um in debt i am a single female
um i'm currently living in an apartment
way to go
and i have started way to go
thank you i i currently have
1410 dollars in my money market account
and i've been working with an
accountability buddy
to help keep me on budget he got me to
help me get a budget
and um now he wants me to i'm working on
baby step three
it should take me to the end of the end
of 2022 to get 12 000
into my money market account and he said
he also wants me to start saving up for
a house for a 20
down payment on a condo and he said he
wants me to put the money in a roth ira
so it can get a little more interest
than a money market
and then he said as soon as you have a
20
down payment for your condo i want you
to pull your money out of your
roth ira plus whatever else i had saved
up
and we're going to put that on a condo
and i i would be buying this on my own
um i know you you want people to do
15-year fix but i'm 55
i just turned 55 and i don't want 1200
mortgage payments in my 70s
and i told him that and he said well
maybe we need to go to a 30-year
mortgage
so you can get smaller payments and then
i said i could just treat that like a
debt snowball
in baby step two so if i my current
rent is 844 dollars which is 25
of my take-home pay because you said
don't get a mortgage greater than 25
of your take-home pay so that would mean
i would need a mortgage right around 850
well your mentor is telling your mentor
is telling you a lot of the same things
we tell you but he's
telling you a few things different than
we tell you right
i need to know your way what is the best
way or the wisest way to do this
what do you make you're making 40 000 a
year
67 308.
when do you plan on retiring
70 72 71 somewhere in there
okay all right uh before dave comes back
in to give you some more
some more wisdom because he could
definitely help out with this this age
break-in
uh one of the things i i don't like that
your uh
mentor is telling you to park the money
in a roth ira
that's a bad move um i would i could i
could definitely see you parking that
into like a mutual fund like an s p
500 um if it's going to be about three
to five years and that's a great route
but if you put in time if you put it
inside a retirement account you're gonna
pay interest and penalties uh
not interest you don't pay penalties um
and so i i don't want that to happen
uh so that's the very first thing and
then for me i could be in
here and dave please quit me if i'm
wrong but i
at this age bracket i'm not in a rush to
move like do you have to move into a
home
like do you i don't need to move in um
he just said
you're paying 850
a month in rent right now and he said
rent is only going to go
up but debbie you're 70. i agree i agree
that it's going to go up and i don't
want you i do want you to get in the
home ownership position
because it'll stabilize your budgeting
as you go into retirement um but i would
not do more than a 15-year fixed
i think you can do better than end of
2022 to finish your emergency fund that
sounds like
that's taking too long to me definitely
don't use a roth completely agree with
anthony on that
use a roth for your retirement savings
but not for your saving up for a house
and no we don't do a 30 we do a 15.
because you don't want a 30 you'll pay
off in 30 years you know what 15 will
pay off in 15 years
and and you're going to do it you're
going to be okay you're going to select
a home that fits that
and you don't have to put down a full 20
to purchase
it just saves you pmi if you do it saves
your private mortgage insurance if you
do
so what i would do is finish this
emergency fund
faster i would not use a roth i would do
a 15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
but i think you've got some other stuff
coming out of this check that you're not
counting here
take-home pay when we say a fourth of
your take-home pay
we don't mean after health insurance
after retirement
or after payments you're paying out of
your check we mean after taxes
yeah and 67 000 should be bringing home
more than you're bringing home or just
after taxes so you got something else
coming out of your check there
or you're getting a big refund and
you're going to need to adjust your w-4s
and get your refund down to where it's
zero you don't want to be getting a big
refund every year
so you should be getting home with more
cash than you're getting home with
unless you've got it going to health
insurance or something inside your
your check there but take-home pay is
not
um uh it is only only means
after taxes not after everything else so
i think you're gonna be able to afford a
house a little condo like you're talking
about get it on a fixed rate a 15-year
and um you know you do not want to go
into retirement
the ending the end of your life with a
bunch of debt
still on a house because you took out a
30 and hoped
you were going to snowball it no just
don't buy it if you can't put it on a
15. yeah
but i think you can and i think you'll
be able to figure it out
good call and you're doing really good
great
she knows her numbers she does she knows
exactly where she is she does
she does now dave let me ask you this
question though because uh it's a
learning experience for me
when i hear someone of that age and
educate me and tell me where i'm wrong
at
my thinking i i get a little nervous to
tell my grandmother to go to go buy a
home
you know what i'm saying like because
there's so much more responsibilities
than just the mortgage payment
that comes with that well a condo i mean
a condo doesn't have the exterior
maintenance you're absolutely right
the interior maintenance and stuff
here's the problem the number the
largest item in your personal budget the
typical person's personal budget is
their mortgage payment
true and it's a rent payment and it's if
it's a rent payment it's going to go up
every year
if it's mortgage payment it's not it's
going to stay flat and when you can get
it paid off
yes you got rid of the biggest item in
your budget in your last
years yeah and you've stabilized
you're destabilized when you're a renter
because you're at other people's house
yes and they can do all kinds of stuff
like make you move and everything else
and so
but you've stabilized your life by
owning
okay and by fixing the payment and or by
getting it paid off completely it's even
more stabilized
makes sense so it's a stabilizing factor
for your
uh last 20 years of life you know
whatever that is if you go say from
uh you know 70 to 90 or something like
that that kind of a thing now you know
the older you are the more you think
okay
but um you know my grandpa used to say
i'm not buying green bananas you know so
uh you know you you do start to think
about what you're purchasing and so
forth but um
coleman and i took a call the other day
from a lady said she was going to sell
her land to her 85 year old
uncle and i'm like why is he buying land
you know it's just
but but but it's okay i just you know
what what is the thought process behind
that in his case he had a good thought
process
but but um
it's the same reason we teach people
with the baby steps millionaire the
everyday millionaires to
people doing the baby steps to become
millionaires they become everyday
millionaires
to get their home paid off because
that's one of the bigger elements of
wealth building yes
as well that's one of the two things
that most of the millionaires have done
they've got their home paid off okay
and uh so it's still all parlays in
there together but
but uh you know if you're 92 it makes no
sense you know maybe not
yeah you know i you know i hope you
lived 107
right but um but the statistical
averages are not
in your favor at that point so no i
probably wouldn't go by then but she's
only 55. i mean
she's got life expectancy of uh
30 years at this point so average death
age of a female in america
right now 74 of a male is 72
but that includes infant mortality and
teenage death and so
when you make it healthy into your 50
late 50s early 60s you've got a very
high statistical likelihood
of making it into your 90s very high
uh and so that i mean that's just
because that's the way the averages work
out
yeah so it's good questions good
discussion this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 14 15 the
simple believe
anything but the prudent give thought
to their steps bobby and i said the key
is not the will to win everybody has
that
it is the will to prepare to win
that is important there you go
robert sweaters robertson minneapolis hi
robert how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um the question about
going through a divorce
long story short my wife and i went
through your program
paid everything off and now she wants a
change of lifestyle
and so i need to buy her half off the
house is paid for
401k savings accounts all fully funded
question is do i use a qdro and roll my
401k over to her
or with the interest rates can should i
go borrow money against the house
not sure what to do
[Music]
i'm sorry yeah
uh what's the house worth
uh probably 350. why are you wanting it
um just because i don't feel like going
through more change right now
and until i figure out which direction
my life's going i just
thought i'd just keep the house for now
so you need about 150 to buy her out
right
for the house but all the other assets i
i need probably
around the 300 price range
what other assets uh 401ks
uh i mean you gotta yeah so how much is
in the 401k
uh i have about 340 in there right now
okay so she's getting half that she's
getting half the house right
pretty much yeah so you could give her
the whole 401k and keep the house
correct
do you have anything else
well all the cars i get boats uh she has
a small 401k but that's all tallied up
in there
basically i'm gonna have to give her
about 300 000 for her to walk away she
doesn't want anything she already
she's just up and left she wants to
start
living like no other now rather than
later
what do you make uh
with overtime i'm right around that 120.
how old are you i'm 47.
okay is it just bothers me that you have
no money in a paid for
house because that's where you're going
to end up
and so you got to go you got to go like
you got to go gangbusters into
retirement now
and build it right right and that's
that's what
basically i'm asking is do i take out a
mortgage and go gangbusters on that no i
no
go gangbusters or do i half and half it
or no
i would i would just do the the qrdo on
the 401k and
clear the house but i'm not sure i want
to do that i i'm
uh but i mean if you're going to keep
the house that's the way to do it
i'm just questioning whether you should
keep the house
yes probably in the future uh once i
you know like i said i was pretty taken
aback from all this and
uh you know just right now you know i
got to make a decision
quickly and i just
looking at options and thought you know
until i figure out
what i want to what do you uh what do
you do for a living
i am a maintenance supervisor
how long have you been doing that
uh i've been in the maintenance field
pretty much my whole life but i
just got promoted a supervisor here
about two years ago
how long ago was this announcement made
by her that you were divorcing uh
four weeks okay
um this is not what you want to do
but it's what you should do you need to
drag this out a little bit
slow down okay because you're still
reeling from the news
and six months from now you're probably
selling this house
and so i think you're selling this house
and giving her her half
and you do the qr do
on her half of the 401k and then you
come out with 150 000
to go buy another property and
uh she comes out 150 000 cash and you've
got
uh you've still got your 401k going and
i think that's going to end up
five years from now having been a better
decision yeah i would have echoed that
you know i i i want you to take as
much time as you can as you need to be
able to process emotionally the change
that's why i'm telling you to drag it
out
absolutely and that's why i was
saying i'm just going to stay in the
house for now until i figure out
process the change i guess so yeah does
she not want the house herself
no no she wants the money she wants to
start living like no other right now
okay yeah she she actually
brought that up like six months ago that
you know we should
sell the house and move to a
you know apartment or something and
start you know
retirement early i guess is in her eyes
but
here's another thing too that i want to
add it may not happen but i'm just
saying
if you could drag this out a little bit
like dave said she may end up changing
her mind
about this situation as well
yeah yeah you're you're you're you're
making the decision
in the heat of battle right now
and i um and i don't blame you for that
i would be too
i understand that and but we have the
anthony i have the benefit of standing
on the sidelines and making the call
rather than being in the game and have
to make the call
um and so it's easier to be a monday
morning quarterback i
understand that but yeah i i um
i just got a feeling that that if you
had a little bit more time to
emotionally process
this you could release this house and
just to be sold and i'll split it
and i think five years from today that's
going to have been a better move for you
i just want you to give yourself time to
emotionally process it you feel like
it's chop chop you gotta do it right now
and nobody says that you can say this is
gonna take three months and we're gonna
have to think about it
all right hard to do that though
it really is so it's easy to bring
something to an end if something's
coming to an end it's easy to get it to
the end you know
yeah but um yeah very hard robert i'm so
sorry
i can hear the pain in your voice
brother you know dave this is why i
spend a lot of time talking to
you know i have a huge tribe of single
people just make sure that you're making
the right decision upfront don't want to
make people feel bad who are going
through divorces but if we can help you
get married
the right way and stay married one time
it's a whole lot
easier down the road you know and as a
single person that's why i'm looking at
people like yourself and sharon and my
parents
because we're going to go through some
hard times but i'm going to go through
the hard times and i want the hard times
to end me and my my future wife so
you know you know it this is sad
you know it's this is our third call
today around divorces
and just hearing that the stress behind
the money what do i do do i cash in my
401k
do i do this you know a divorce turns a
marriage into a business transaction
one of my buddies says it does divorce
recovery and it occurs to me then at
this point really what you're doing
assuming it is 100 over okay this is a
negotiation now
and um the law will give her 50
that's the truth but if she's really
desperate to just take off into whatever
you probably could negotiate for a lot
less than 50 yeah
if you're willing to make the decision
quickly yeah yeah
you know i just want to be free okay how
free you want to be how quick you
how much you willing to pay for that
quick freedom because otherwise it's
going to take a little while
and uh you know because he with the most
patience in a negotiation wins
america may hate me after this one but
this is why i'm i'm strongly james
considering a prenup as a single man
uh-oh now now we got a whole another
show to do that's why i said it right
towards the end of the show
just as the music comes up he drops a
grenade in my studio
same sends it right over hey don't drag
me into this
[Laughter]
good show anthony good show james and
kelly what great work today
that puts this hour the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you